olá pessoal é só o joão
eu sou o lúcio para começar a nossa fala
eu gostaria de trazer um dado em 2016 o
sistema de avaliação de ensino do rio do
sul saers esse dado nos dias que em
torno de 93 por cento dos alunos que
realizaram a avaliação tem dificuldades
em matemática estão abaixo do nível
esperado de matemática é um número
bastante ruim a gente pode com certeza
extrapolar esse número para outras
regiões do brasil
tá mas e aí fica a pergunta o que a
gente poderia fazer
nós como educadores pra melhorar esse
índice a eu queria trazer para vocês um
pouco da minha experiência a aaa o que
me levou a gostar da área de exatas
quando era pequeno minha realidade era
muito mais próxima eu gostar de
agricultura e veterinária
mas sempre me chamou atenção o que faz
um dispositivo eletrônico funcionar como
é que é eu conseguia apertar um botão e
ele me dava uma resposta para vocês
terem uma idéia é uma coisa que me
marcou muito foi quando meu primeiro
jogo estragou eu conseguir deslanchar
ele eu consegui ver como é que ele
funcionava e fiquei em torno de um mês
ali tentando modificar ele fazer ele
fazer outras outras possibilidades
eu acho que tudo isso contribuiu para
mim ser um cientista da computação hoje
pra mim gostar da área de exatas
essa experiência toda a infância e me
trouxe para essa área eu nunca tive medo
de uma matemática física é bem pelo
contrário eu achava divertido porque
ouvia a função daquilo nas coisas que eu
estava olhando que eu estudava eu gostar
pela parte de exatas começou na infância
foi levado pelo meu irmão então colega
algum brinquedo principalmente que tinha
odin as motor
o efeito luminoso ou sonoro e logo já
iria desmontar meus pais ficavam muito
chateado então onde é uma questão de
respeito disso né e e depois já estava
desmontado já tinha sido xingado já
estava eu lá junto com ele tenta
remontar então essas peças e desenvolver
um novo brinquedo
então hoje ele está na área de
engenharia mecânica e eu na área de
engenharia elétrica então que esse breve
resumo antes pode colocar como sendo uma
conclusão destas breves histórias que
colocou aqui
a robótica é formada basicamente por
três pilares são a parte de mecânica
a parte eletrônica ea parte de
computação e o segundo ponto que está
colocando aqui pra vocês é que as
crianças e adolescentes são muito
curiosas
eles gostam de visualizar coisas novas
que gostam de experimentar então um dos
pontos que está aqui é chamada robótica
maker então que a robótica mente você me
desenvolver dispositivos sejam eles de
movimentação seja ele sonoros sejam eles
luminosos ea parte da programação de
pequenos periférico simplesmente
desenvolver alguma aplicação na área
então a idéia de fazer um elo um elo
entre alguns pontos e esse ponto seria
então o aluno que é o curioso
a robótica com essa ferramenta esse meio
é daqui e se sim então ou reforce
conteúdos de física matemática assim
lógico e entra outro ponto é que é o
professor então esse professor
nós professores vamos ser o protagonista
da história para motivar esses alunos a
trabalharem esses conteúdos reforçar os
conteúdos das áreas que estão leciona
como é que a gente pode fazer isso aí
então a idéia é além do quadro de giz e
além da lousa
a gente também tem outras ferramentas
para trabalhar em sala de aula como por
exemplo o martelo a chave de fenda o
parafuso o alicate
mas como é que a gente faz isso como é
que vai motivar os alunos a trabalharem
com as ferramentas aproveitar os
insights das nossas áreas né seja
biologia matemática física português e
faz os alunos se motivarem a trabalho
robótico
e visualizar essa área de estudos também
nesse conceito bom
a robótica maker né háháhá
ela está muito difundida pela inclusive
pela facilidade que se tenha acesso a
esse tipo de conteúdo na hoje no mundo
digital que a gente vive
se eu for acessar qualquer site o vídeo
eu vou encontrar referências para como
eu consigo construir um pequeno robô por
mais simples que seja feito de papelão
com alguns motores de brinquedos usados
é certo então há o acesso a esse tipo de
informação tá muito fácil
o que nós temos que fazer agora como
educadores é tentar trazer esse tipo de
coisa pra dentro da sala de aula
já foi comprovado que os alunos têm mais
facilidade de aprender quando ele tem
gestos concretos pra visualizar o
resultado daquilo que estão
desenvolvendo por exemplo eu posso pegar
uma simples engrenagem de um brinquedo e
lá no matemática trabalhar o conceito de
ângulo ou na física trabalhar o conceito
de velocidade então trazê aquela aquele
objeto para dentro da sala de aula e
relacionar com os mais diversos
conteúdos não precisa ficar restrito a
somente a exatas eu posso desenvolver um
robô que tem um tipo de movimento
comparar com algum algum animal fazer
esse tipo de ligação puxá la ao
conhecimento da biologia e assim por
diante
e onde é que a gente consegue ver os
primeiros resultados disso há o jogo vai
falar um pouquinho agora sobre a
experiência que a gente tem então br é
além da sala de aula de trabalhar com a
parte robótica
mesmo no ensino superior também né
o ensino fundamental até o ensino
superior mas tem um evento onde
participa anualmente que é o br empresa
de robótica tem as etapas regionais
estaduais que a gente acaba organizando
na universidade
então como é que ela funciona a temática
é a robótica né gente utiliza matemática
é um desafio que os alunos também têm
que desenvolver que é o desafio é uma
temática de ter uma simulação do
ambiente um desastre onde a gente você
tem que ser resgatada através de robôs
como é que faz então isso então ele
recebe o desafio onde precisa montar e
programar um robô autónomo para poder
então é atravessar áreas desconhecidas
subir rampas e desviar de obstáculos e
ao final se consegue resgatar então
essas vítimas
nós percebemos ao longo desse tempo que
a gente vem acompanhando já são em torno
de 10 a 18 anos que a gente vem
acompanhando a única de robótica a
evolução de muitos alunos são muitas
carinhas já a conhecidas desde as
primeiras edições
a gente tem a depoimentos desses alunos
que o participar dessa olimpíada de
robótica o incentivo do professor
durante as atividades de robótica que
eles têm na sala de aula
fizeram-lhe para eles perderem o medo de
descobrir como é que funciona uma coisa
descobrir um novo uma nova forma de
calcular na matemática é uma nova
operação e assim por diante
foram vários alunos que vieram durante a
durante olimpíadas ou mesmo em outros
momentos nos relatar a eu gosto das
atividades robótica porque ela me da
base me dá me mostra tudo aquilo que eu
aprendi que eu posso usar tudo aquilo
que eu tô aprendendo uma de uma forma
mais concreta
além dos relatos que ele tem na própria
competição na qual o desafio com os
alunos do ensino fundamental e médio né
mas nos procuram os corredores da cidade
estão os cds são os alunos que estão
vindo da parte robótica é relatando
partilhando como foi importante essa
atividade durante esses períodos que
tiveram no ensino médio e fundamental
então acho que esse é um principal ponto
que deixa como se a nossa semente aqui
nessa conversa
obrigado gado
[Aplausos]